here we go Junior I economics you can
always expect an interesting one from
junior eyes he's asking is it doing good
a simple basic natural thing for humans
to do do you have an idea why a how-to
is needed yeah I think it is um I think
actually you guys get it you know we're
sort of probably preaching to convert it
on this black but but the practical
thing is we need to bring it to life and
I just think if you're building
successful businesses mantra nerves and
covering all the other stuff like
getting with capital and stuff to cover
on the blacks there wouldn't be amazing
to share that engine for prosperity in a
wider community and do good I think
everybody's got humanity of their art
and we've got a strong moral compass and
particularly nerves in the day of
suggested a really the case so yeah it's
kind of a no-brainer to me and I think
it's something that you're absolutely
right you kind of could got it from the
get-go and if you scale you company you
have more impact we're very lucky so you
know if I look at areas like Atlanta
we've got a thousand folks their
colleagues and that means that ticket a
bit about 40,000 hours volunteering goes
into community so makes a big difference
so even even if you find people though
you can make a difference and and it's
kind of pretty cool when you have your
monthly meetings or go down to the pub
or you have some wins to connect that to
why me and the more successful you are
to Evans point you can you can give back
more the more successful you are and I
know a lot of companies who have when
they groped office they give a
percentage i know a lot of startup
companies and come as I've invested in
who from the get-go they said ten
percent of our profits would give to
charities that really matter to us and
make a difference I think there's still
a stigma that business is just greedy in
bad and evil and ripping people off i
don't know but the culture in britain
but i know in north america distilled at
that email
and so when people are thinking about
giving back to me not they may not see
it through a corporate I wear that's the
point of this session 2 in trance Fred
awareness and and even you know Steven
leading by example with all the things
that he's doing with sage foundation his
own personal time and stories I think
it's just to try to raise the awareness
that that you can do good in a business
context and really business is about
like really a business by providing
value if you're providing value you're
in business and see you're providing
value by helping customers do something
you know so you're doing good through
your product or service but then if
you're fortunate to make a good profit
off of that then also use some of that
to contribute back and build the
community because then everybody wins
yeah vinod say also you don't do these
flaps you don't do what you're doing to
be the next bill Gates you do it because
you're passionate you believe and I'm
looking at that bull barn you wrote that
book of your passionate and I know you
get a kick out mentoring people coaching
people and enjoy and see in their
success and I yeah it's really there is
a massive stigma particularly since like
2008 and the banking crisis with all
this kind of concept of fat cats and a
few other things i think you know we are
the community of entrepreneurs on this
blab we need to we do create a big
shadow what you guys say to your
colleagues price massive impact and it's
little things you know everyone i joined
this company for whatever reason the
previous chief executive had a private
jet or access to a private jet when i'm
in toronto I move down the street I jump
in a cab or in this city great City of
London um I walked 20 minutes till
meeting today I've got the chew in New
York go get on the metro you know I I
just kind of thing at the end they we
don't realize we're very privileged to
serve the responsibility we feel for our
customers or stakeholders our colleagues
is immense and when I woke up every
month at do we think about wow what
14,000 colleague
where their mortgages are dependent on
our success our customers their whole
financial systems that abandon our
success their collection catching their
customers anacin and soph responsibility
and all all we're talking about here
it's just extending that responsibility
the community to serve and it could be
little things if any of you guys if
you're in downtown Montreal actually
Vancouver you mentioned it's beautiful
today I'll our vessel it's because some
of the best restaurants in the world you
got the the water you look up at the
mountains all my god on that Vancouver
but what a problem around homeless Lee
you can walk down the street and and
then I said it beginning there but for
the grace of God go probably any of us
if we're going wrong peer group you know
hit the bottle whatever there's
something in everybody's that no one's
perfect and we could have been met so as
entrepreneurs I think we cast a massive
shadow and I think you're right Evan and
I think over one of the missions would
have as a community is to actually
explain to the rest of the population
about the humanity of what we're trying
to do it's not about greed it's about
really making a difference about
creating a legacy it's about being proud
of the businesses that you've run and
creating something I use this phrase a
lot it's great you know what I'm my
mission for sage is great something
special unique and magical for everybody
involved